der geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin in
kürze endet ihre amtszeit nach 16 jahren
nach beinahe sechs 1000 tagen an der
regierungsspitze nach unzähligen reden
verhandlungen entscheidungen gipfel
gipfel nächten sie haben sie eingesetzt
und haben sich selbst viel abverlangt
das erkennt meine fraktion auch an ich
sage aber auch nach 16 jahren
kanzlerschaft nach fast 6000 tagen unter
ihrer führung mit spd oder fdp braucht
unser land dringend einen
regierungswechsel ich stimme ihm zu es
geht um einen rekruten
das land ist heute
sozial kulturell politisch tiefer
gespalten als zu beginn ihrer
kanzlerschaft
sie hinterlassen ein land im krisen
zustand und nicht wenige bürgerinnen und
bürger die das vertrauen in die
staatliche kompetenz der krisenlösung
immer mehr verliebt verlieren wir
kolleginnen und kollegen krisen werden
nicht mehr gelöst sondern sie werden
verwaltet ministerinnen und minister
werden nicht an ihrer leistung gemessen
sondern durchgeschleppt bis zum schluss
eingeschlichen hat sie in 16 jahren eine
unkultur der politischen
verantwortungslosigkeit meine damen und
herren und das muss trennen werden
die beregnung kollegen nach 16 jahren an
der spitze eines landes das ist ja die
gelegenheit ein land zu prägen und
politisches vermächtnis zu hinterlassen
ich habe genau zugehört was das sein
soll hat ja vielleicht ein
zukunftsfähiger sozialstaat oder
ähnliches sein können sie haben über
digitalisierung gesprochen dass das so
toll ist ich kann nur sagen schon vor 16
jahren wurde gesagt deutschland soll
weltmeister bei der digitalisierung
seien wie ist die realität wir sind
hinten drittel meine damen und herren
gucke ich doch die schulen an bei der
digitalisierung waren das ist eines der
grössten skandale und ich will ihnen
sagen was bleibt unser land hat sich
auseinander entwickelt und will ihnen
ein beispiel sagen 2006 lebten 18,6
prozent der kinder unter der
armutsgrenze und im jahr 2009 10 sind es
die kinderarmut in unserem land ist
gestiegen 2020 leben fast zwei millionen
minderjährige in hartz4 familie das ist
ihre bilanz und ich filme auf ihren
eigenen um an ihren maßstäben das zu
messen in ihrem koalitionsvertrag steht
auf seite 21 wir werden kinderrechte im
grundgesetz ausdrücklich verankern
kinder sind rund rechtsträger ihre
rechte haben für uns verfassungsrang was
haben sie gemacht gar nichts haben sie
gemacht das zeigt die wertschätzung der
kinder der heranwachsenden unserem land
und ich finde das ist skandalös dass sie
bei kinderarmut bei den heranwachsenden
so versagte meine damit
die bundesregierung hat das vertrauen in
staatliche handlungsfähigkeit in
vorsorge und sicherheit extrem
eingeschränkt und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen nach 18 monaten pandemie ist
eine frage überhaupt nicht geklärt ich
finde im übrigen dass es richtig war
dass geholfen worden ich finde auch die
neuverschuldung richtig haben wir vieles
zu kritisieren gehabt an einzelmaßnahmen
aber kurzarbeitergeld unterstützung von
unternehmen und soweit alles in ordnung
aber die zentrale frage wer zahlt die
krise die wird nicht beantwortet oder
ich kann es auch ganz anders fragen
warum sollen diejenigen die dieses land
am laufen halten warum sollen die
krankenschwester der paketbote der
busfahrer die korona rechnung wieder
bezahlen vormerken und herr scholz 20
jahre sollen die menschen die kredite ab
stocke dass ihr plan aber nur in fünf
jahren von 2013 bis 2018 sind die
vermögen der reichsten haushalte in
deutschland fast um die hälfte gewachsen
sie bitten wieder die normalbürger zur
kasse und schon die fetten konnten und
das ist inakzeptabel
wir haben regeln vorschlag gemacht wir
haben gegen vorschlag gemacht der steht
sie waren grundgesetz artikel 106 eine
einmalige vermögensabgabe unter konrad
adenauer genauso angewendet worden war
übrigens kein leger und das diw keine
vorfeldorganisation der linken hat das
geprüft praktikabel sagen die unser
vorschlag trifft nur 0,7 prozent der
bevölkerung nur die allerreichsten im
land das sind diejenigen die union und
fdp immer sachspenden die sollen
betroffen werden und ich sage es ist
feige weil sie sich nicht mit den
superreichen anlegen und es ist unsozial
weil sie die schuldenlast das land
weiter spalten wird meine damen und
herren dann muss ich das man muss sich
das mal konkret vorstellen
die krankenpflegerin die korona
patienten rettet bezahlt mit ihrem
steuergeld die staatshilfen die an bmw
bezahlt werden und bmw schüttet dieses
geld in form von dividenden aus unter
anderem an eine frau klatten deren
vermögen täglich täglich um drei
millionen täglich um drei millionen
steigen warum fordern diese idee warum
fordern sie dieses geld nicht zurück
staatshilfen kassieren und dividenden
ausschütten dass es inakzeptabel
die kolleginnen und kollegen das alte
leistungs und wohlstands versprechen des
landes meinen kindern wird es einmal
besser gehen das geht wenn überhaupt
wird das nur noch eingeschränkt und das
ein sehr schlechter befund für unser
land für unser land und auch ein
ergebnis von 16 jahren angela merkel für
ein deutschland wie wir gut und gerne
leben haben sie vor der letzten wahl
versprochen haben sie das geschafft und
wenn ja für wen auch da eine zahl
jedem dritten arbeitnehmer und jeder
dritten arbeitnehmerin in vollzeit
wohlgemerkt brot nach 45 jahren eine
rente von unter 1100 euro netto das ist
ein armutsrisiko und das ist nicht
hinnehmbar meine damen und herren
deutschland ein hochlohnland für viele
menschen ist das ein märchen deutschland
hat ein gewaltiges lohnproblem und das
belastet im übrigen auch die
sozialkassen er schaut sie haben über
die altenpflegerin gerät ich will sie
mal darauf aufmerksam machen 17.000
pflegerinnen und altenpfleger in unserem
land müssen zum sozialamt und aufstocken
weil sie von ihrem lohn nicht leben
können das ist doch beschämend meine
damen und herren das ist die wahrheit
klatschen nicht handeln
die helden des alltags ist sie an der
kasse teilweise ihr leben riskiert haben
oder ihre gesundheit zumindest haben
weniger einer tasche und gleichzeitig
scheffeln die eigentümer der ketten
milliarden das doch optionen und dann
haben sie was zu den renten gesagt herr
scholz die renten stabil die renten
seien stabil und wir wollen sie stabil
halten was denken sie eigentlich fast
schon rentner der 45 jahre gearbeitet
hat und 2650 euro bekommen hat ist der
durchschnittsverdienst was denken sie
was der so kriegt nach 45 jahren ich
kann es ihnen sagen
1100 euro netto das ist nicht stabil und
wenn überhaupt ist sehr niedrig stabil
45 jahre nahezu durchschnittsverdiener
und dann soziale abstieg im alter das
ist die realität in denen gut und gerne
deutschland frau merkel und die
sozialdemokraten lieber olaf scholz seit
habt ihr 19 jahre regiert und davon
haben wir 19 jahre die zuständigkeit für
rente gehabt und diese 19 jahren war für
die rentner stabil schlecht und das muss
sich ändern wir brauchen eine große
rentenreform
es ist doch nicht erklärbar ist doch
nicht erklären dass ein rentner in
hamburg im schnitt 800 euro weniger
rente bekommt als in renten in salzburg
und da gibt es gründe für dann gibt es
gründe für beim gleichen verdienst die
arbeitnehmer in deutschland der
stärksten wirtschaft europas werden mit
unterdurchschnittlichen renten
abgespeist das ist nicht akzeptieren
damit muss schluss sein die löhne und
die renten müssen steigen leistung muss
ich für die wahren leistungsträger
wieder nun meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
im jahr 2009 10 haben 40 personen
jeweils mehr als 100 millionen geerbt
oder geschenkt bekommen und davon haben
immerhin 31 0 steuern bezahlt haben über
100 millionen geerbt haben null steuern
bezahlt aber bei der arbeitsleistung der
bürger da greifen sie voll zu das hat
überhaupt nichts mit leistungsgerecht
ich zu tun hätten gebrauchen entlastung
bei den geringverdienern und bei der
mittelschicht
allerhöchste zeit für große steuerreform
nach unseren vorschlägen hätte die
krankenschwester der busfahrer 100 euro
mehr im monat oder familien mit kleinen
und geringen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen hätten 500 euro im monat mehr
das hat das diw errechnet ich finde das
ist dringend notwendig und bei den
energiekosten damit war sie eine
glanzleistung am ende ihrer rede die
mieterinnen und mieter tragen allein die
mehrkosten für den co2 preis bei heizung
und warmwasser kalt duschen sollen die
mieter das empfehlen die immobilie leute
block und leute aus ihrer fraktion frau
merkel muss die verschwundene bisschen
früh
ich finde das ist eine unverschämtheit
liebe kollegen pflegen noch ein wort zur
klimapolitik die bundeskanzlerin hat
gesagt klimawandel funktioniert nur wenn
die menschen mitgenommen werden was ist
denn die realität familien zahlen in
diesem jahr 600 euro mehr für energie
aber ihr versprechen wahr doch mit der
klimapolitik die bürgerinnen und bürger
zu entlasten wo ist denn die entlastung
den strompreis wollten sie senken aber
in deutschland wird um 1 30 prozent
höherer strompreis als sonst in europa
gezahlt was ist denn das für eine
politik von herrn alten maya gute
besserung im übrigen ich hab den
verkehrsminister gefragt was dann von
der co2 preise im januar wieder in die
emotions senkung bis 2025
2,5 prozent madonna wetter sie
verbessern die situation in fünf jahren
um 2,5 prozent und dafür ziehen sie den
leuten beim tanken beim heizen das geld
aus der tasche ihre klimapolitik ist
ineffizient und sie ist teuer meine
damen und herren der verkehrsminister
aus geantwortet der güterverkehr
bei guter verkehr wird nicht zeit war es
schrittweise von der straße auf die
schiene verlegt nein man könnte es ja
annehmen wenn man die pariser klimaziele
erreichen will nein es gibt genau in die
andere richtung neue rekorde auf der
straße und rückgang auf der schiene
promis runter von der straße und ein
masterplan für den güterverkehr das wäre
die richtige maßnahme meine damen und
herren aber es geht natürlich das geht
natürlich nicht wenn die csu das
verkehrsministerium der zwölf jahren
führt bahnkunden autofahrer und
radfahrer haben was besseres verdient
als die csu meine damen und herren
will eine bemerkung zum thema
afghanistan sagen weil es hier noch mal
eine große rolle spielt und ich will
daran erinnern gerhard schröder und
joschka fischer haben deutschland in
diesem krieg geführt und der einsatz ist
der schwärzeste punkt in ihrer
außenpolitischen bilanz vor merkel
keines der ziele was in den mandats
begründungen und ich kann ihnen nur
empfehlen die alle noch mal zu lesen
keines dieser ziele wurde erreicht meine
damen und herren und ich will in dieser
an dieser stelle war sehr sehr deutlich
sagen nicht die partei die 20 jahre
gegen den krieg und die im übrigen für
die frühzeitige evakuierung sich hier im
bundestag eingesetzt gemeinsam mit
grünen und sogar mit der fpd liegt die
ist verantwortungslos sondern andere
haben außenpolitisch und
sicherheitspolitisch verantwortungslos
agiert diejenigen die 20 jahre das leben
von soldaten gefährdet haben die zu
toten geführt haben die sind
verantwortlich oder der große brömer
sagt haben die rettungsflüge abgelegt
das einfach mal völlig falsch wir haben
das hier beantragt sie haben es
abgelehnt und dann haben sie hier ein
schlimmes mandat vorgelegt den man nicht
zustimmen konnte wir wollten so viel wie
möglich evakuieren das wollen wir im
übrigen noch heute ihre bilanz ist doch
verheerend 138 ortskräfte und da tun sie
sich noch dicke das gegenteil ist der
fall verantwortungs politik vor der
politik läuft anders
und wenn es ein ergebnis gibt da muss
man doch über 1 ganz klar sagen
interventionen und beteiligungen
eskalation das ist nun wirklich
dramatisch gescheitert und da auch eine
erinnerung an ihre legislatur in diesen
vier jahren haben sie für
22,5 milliarden
rüstungsexporte genehmigt sie
exportieren den tod und die konzerne
verdient blutige profite mit diesem geld
das ist inakzeptabel rüstungsexporte
auch nach afghanistan nach pakistan
das geht nun nicht meine damen
ich sage ihnen ganz klar wir wollen
nicht
dass deutschland von einem laster ist
auch schon gegangen und ich rede gehen
hier also das ist ein zeichen dass
deutschland von der last von herrn merz
herrn scheuerl auch von herrn linda den
weg zurück in die neoliberale
mottenkiste gehen wir machen eine
politik für millionen und nicht für
millionäre millionen im land würden
profitieren von einem höheren
mindestlohn von zwölf oder 13 euro
millionen würden mit unserem
steuerkonzept krankenschwestern paket
wurden deutlich entlastet meine damen
und herren und endlich würden wir eine
kindergrundsicherung durchsetzen können
damit kinderarmut ernsthaft bekämpft
wird gemeinsam mit grünen und
und millionen rentnerinnen und rentner
müssten nicht mehr um ihr auskommen
banken meine damen und herren weil alle
einzahlen müssen auch sie hier alle
müssen in die rentenkasse einzahlt ja am
26 september geht es um eine
richtungsentscheidung und ich sage ganz
klar die staatspolitisch verwahrloste
union masken deals aserbaidschan affäre
fc eigene tasche wiederhole ich hier
gerne die müssen raus aus der regierung
die bürgerinnen und bürger wollen keinen
unions regierung mehr und wollen auch
nicht dass seine fdp in die regierung
kommt wie am 15 märz noch herrenjacke in
thüringen mit gewählt hat die frage ist
ganz einfach linke oder lindner ist die
frage ob spd und grüne real ihr
wahlprogramm umsetzen wollen ich will
zum schluss gerne den satz von christian
lindner abgewandelt wiederholen es ist
besser gut mit der linken zu regieren
als falsch mit linda zu regieren unser
land brauche ein politikwechsel eine
soziale
das ist unser angebot an die bürgerinnen
und bürger herzlichen dank
[Applaus]